we are expecting new testimony today
about the crime scene in that double
murder trial of disbarred South Carolina
lawyer Alex Murdoch the trial was held
up briefly yesterday when the courthouse
was evacuated over a security threat
jurors heard new details of Murdoch's
alleged financial fraud prosecutors
claimed his desire to cover up those
crimes gave birth okomotive to kill his
wife and his son he has pleaded not
guilty and he denies the allegations of
the murder our Nikki Batiste is at the
courthouse in South Carolina she is
covering the trial Nikki good morning
David good morning Murdoch allegedly
stole Millions from his client yesterday
we heard from one of his former
colleagues at his South Carolina law
firm who said she discovered evidence he
committed fraud she also described
Murdoch as a family man who appeared
devastated after his wife and son were
killed
on day 13 of Alex Murdoch's double
murder trial paralegal Annette Griswold
described a paper trail of missing
client fees raising concerns the once
prominent lawyer was mishandling the
funds including charges related to what
the firm called the ferris case but she
said she put those fears on hold one
Murdoch's wife and son were murdered
were you at all concerned about finding
out what happened to these Ferris fees
after that happened what Fierce fees
yeah what Fierce fees that was the
furthest thing on my mind Griswold said
it wasn't until three months later that
she found a fraudulent check-in
Murdoch's files and reported it I was
hurt I was angry
I just was beside myself and I was
I was a bit enraged too Murdoch's
defense attorneys portrayed him as a
family man whose alleged Financial
crimes had nothing to do with the
murders during cross-examination one of
the former business associates Murdoch
allegedly defrauded the scribes seeing
him at his family's wake he was a broken
man you could tell he was very upset
during that testimony Murdoch looked
solemn at one point appearing to wipe
away tears and just minutes later ladies
and gentlemen we have to evacuate the
building a disruptive moment when
according to law enforcement Courthouse
Personnel received a bomb threat
suspending proceedings for more than two
hours before the court reconvened State
Police are investigating
also under contention yesterday a blue
raincoat found on Murdoch's mother's
property with gunshot residue on it
prosecutors argue Murdoch may have used
it to carry the murder weapons the
defense claimed it belonged to Murdoch's
father a law enforcement expert said
either scenario was possible Tony
all right Nikki thank you very much